bonsoir travers des rails merci d'être
avec nous dix ans après quel bilan
global si on devait le résumer en
quelques mots c'est difficile d'abord
jour je voulais juste préciser que je ne
suis plus à layrisse médiateur de
recherche avec pse c'est difficile de
résumer en quelques mots une situation
d'une telle intensité et d'une telle
importance pour des peuples qui vont du
maghreb jusqu'aux pays du golfe mais je
crois que ce qui est le plus important à
retenir au delà des bilans c'est que
dans le fond les sociétés arabes se sont
réappropriés leur citoyenneté donc nous
sommes entrés dans un processus
et lorsque je disais il ya un instant
qu'il était beaucoup trop tôt pour faire
un bilan
ces temps c'est à cela que je faisais
allusion le processus peut être long
oui et je peux comprendre notamment pour
le cas de la tunisie dont c'est
l'anniversaire demain de la révolte
je peux comprendre qu'il y ait
énormément de déception d'autant que la
situation économique et sociale est
absolument dramatique pour pour la
jeunesse de ce pays
effectivement à parler de la tunisie on
y reviendra certainement mais aussi
l'egypte de libye du yémen
tous ces pays qui ont pris des
trajectoires pour ainsi dire différentes
lequel d'entre eux se s'en sort le mieux
est lequel d'entre eux peut-être sans
semble le moins bien selon vous voilà là
vous me demandez moi encore une question
très difficile c'était dit qu'ils ne pas
faire de il ira en chine
on veut faire faire d une hiérarchie ou
pas ce que c'est c'est ce sont des
sociétés à la fois très différent ça
tunisie
ça n'est pas la libye la libye ce n'est
pas l'egypte et et c'est encore moins le
yémen donc je crois que ça dépend du
niveau d'éducation du niveau de
développement de toute une société d
élite évidemment intellectuels
universitaires artistique et lorsque
l'on à agréger
tout cela au sein d'une population on
met quand même beaucoup d'atouts de son
côté pour permettre
un pays de passer d'un système politique
à un autre on appelle aujourd'hui les
transitions pour qu'elles se passent en
douceur malheureusement malheureusement
c'est vrai que dix ans après il n'y a
pas eu de résultats aussi probants et
aussi spectaculaire que ce que l'on
attendait en 2010 2011
quels sont selon vous les les
difficultés que l'on retrouve le plus
souvent justement sur le chemin de la
transition
indéniablement je crois que c'est la
question économique 1 on voit ces images
de ces de ces populations notamment en
tunisie qui brandissent ou en égypte là
c'est la face à elle et je crois qu'ils
vont du pain ça veut tout dire
et donc c'est vrai que les situations
sont très très disparates
là aussi et que si on ne parvient pas à
stabiliser la situation dans un premier
temps sur le plan économique pour offrir
des perspectives sociales alors les
évolutions les les progrès sur le plan
institutionnel seront vains et c'est ce
que on observe notamment en egypte c'est
ce que l'on a vu avec la tragédie
syrienne et la guerre civile en libye
également
et puis la tunisie qui est toujours sur
le fil du rasoir est dans la situation
économique est dramatique et qui s'est
accentué avec la pandémie
puisque c'est un pays qui tirait
beaucoup de ces ressources du tourisme
est aujourd'hui comme vous le savez est
quasiment plus de tourisme en tunisie
voire quasiment nul et par conséquent sa
obère les perspectives de redressement
économique
est ce qu'on peut craindre un finalement
de nouveaux soulèvements peut-être
encore plus violent dans ce contexte que
vous nous décrivez si il y à des
soulèvements là je pense par exemple un
pays comme l'algérie
je crois que ça se fera autour des mêmes
questions et des mêmes revendications
que celles qui sont nées en 2000
c'est à dire cette réappropriation de la
citoyenneté
on veut participer à la vie publique on
veut que notre voix compte
on veut participer à la vie politique
démocratique de ce pays est pas avoir
vous voyez bien vous l'avez pris quatre
les quatre exemples qui sont les plus
emblématiques dans le monde arabe la
tunisie l'egypte le yémen et la libye
à chaque fois ce sont minimum 20 ans de
pouvoir autocratique voire dictatorial
dans le cas de l'égypte ou de mouammar
kadhafi sans partage et par conséquent
je crois qu'il faut on est à la fin d'un
cycle et qu'il faut que les populations
participent à la fois la définition et
aux choix et aux orientations de leur
pays aujourd'hui
d'une manière générale vous restez
optimiste justement sur la trajectoire
que vont suivre ces pays là même si vous
ne l'avez très bien décrit la transition
est souvent longue et difficile et le
contexte économique n'aide pas oui oui
je reste résolument optimiste parce que
je crois encore une fois qu'il faut
qu'on fasse l'éloge du processus nous
sommes dans ce processus comme disent
les anglo saxons
donc c'est en cours et je crois qu'il
faut observer à la fois ce qui va pas et
c'est légitime de le relever pour le
corriger
mais il faut aussi souligner que la
situation en 2000 en 7 pendant cette fin
d'année 2020 en tunisie notamment n'a
rien de comparable avec le pays dans
lequel les tunisiens vivaient jusqu'à
décembre 2010 c'est une véritable
démocratie l'état de droit est en
construction
et je crois que c'est un pays qui
dispose de tous les atouts d'une élite
suffisamment formés et éclairé pour
renforcer ces évolutions et parvenir à
faire réussir cette transition
démocratique merci beaucoup khadr dès
rahim
chercheurs dont calypso et non pas à
l'iris on a corrigé pour l'avenir merci
à vous